elle s'est invitée aujourd'hui c'est
vous alexandra goujon bonjour bonjour
merci d'être sur cette plate sur ce
plateau vous êtes maîtresse de
conférences en sciences politiques à
l'université de bourgogne spécialiste de
l'ukraine la biélorussie autrice de
l'ukraine de l'indépendance à la guerre
qui est sorti c'est plus que d'actualité
il ya quelques mois aux éditions du
cavalier bleu le scénario d'une guerre
longue qui se dessine en tout cas plus
long que vraisemblablement je vais
casser le plateau le prévoyaient les
russes c'est ainsi que semble se
dessiner sa de guerre en ukraine ces
jours ci on parle beaucoup de ce à quoi
s'attendait peut-être le kremlin et qui
aurait été vraisemblablement freiné dans
sa progression
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire à quoi
on s'attendait côté ukrainien avant le
début de la guerre ou en tout cas du
côté de ceux qui pensaient que la guerre
allait avoir lieu
alors je pense qu'il y avait 2 2 2 et 2
éléments premiers éléments
et l'ukraine est un pays en guerre
depuis 2014 dont quelque part il ya une
fois à la fois une préparation à la
guerre et puis également une vie avec la
guerre depuis depuis huit ans alors les
les discours notamment de la part des
états unis autour d'une invasion
imminente inquiétait il ya même des
citoyens en fait tu craignant qu'ils se
préparaient on va dire à combattre et
qui durant leurs heures de loisirs
faisait des formations militaires on l'a
vu et dans même temps je crois qu'on ne
croyait pas à une invasion de ce type
peut-être quelque chose pour récupérer
des territoires du côté de la ligne de
front et qui existe encore une fois
depuis depuis 2015 mais cette invasion
de grande ampleur je pense qu'une grande
partie des ukrainiens n'y croyais pas la
veille de cette invasion on vivait
normalement comme le disent la plupart
des ukrainiens et je crois que c'est un
choc le 24 au matin le fait de viser
kiev marioupol on va y revenir dans un
instant je crois que vous connaissez
particulièrement bien odessa bien sûr
quelle ville exceptionnelle avec ce ce
patrimoine il y à des dessins bien sûr
stratégique et militaire mais qu'est ce
que c'est ville 10 de l'ukraine
d'aujourd'hui qui pourrait expliquer en
partie la détermination nous sommes à
les viser et à viser les civils qui y
vivent oui ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
voyez c'est que justement on est en
train de parler du sud de l'ukraine
alors que on est depuis des années sur
cette espèce de division est ouest alors
qu'il ya une certaine réalité mais quand
on parle de l'est et de l'ouest on
oublie et le centre et le sud de
l'ukraine et là ce qu'on voit en parlant
marioupol d'odessa c'est qu'il ya un sud
ukrainiens ou encore de la ville de dirt
et allison qui aujourd'hui en fait têtu
et la grande une des grandes villes au
cul mais voilà alors seville justement
le sud de l'ukraine c'est un sud qui est
qui et qui est russophone comme
d'ailleurs une partie d'une partie de
deux de l'est mais où on voit justement
que et bien les russes ne sont pas
forcément accueilli en libérateur on
parle d'occupants les maires de ces
villes parle d'occupation russes il y en
a dans une toute petite plus petites
villes ont verdir melli topol ce maire a
été kidnappé
et la population en fait manifeste pour
retrouver le maire et pour dire que
effectivement à cette ville et cette
ville et ukrainienne et ils demandent la
plupart du temps aux russes de partir
est-ce que c'est aussi parce que c'était
des villes du vivre ensemble à
l'ukrainienne justement oui en fait en
ukraine on essaye d'expliquer le conflit
depuis 2014 à travers cette idée voilà
deux conflits linguistiques de conflits
ethniques et en fait dans le sud de
l'ukraine mais compris à kiev voilà on
est dans la une diversité en fait en
ukraine on a une diversité à la fois
j'allais dire dans ces villes là mais
aussi on a une diversité régionale qui
n'empêche pas en fait le fait de se
sentir ukrainien toutes ces personnes en
fait ont la citoyenneté ukrainienne
depuis 30 ans et il y a eu tout un
travail de construction nationale et
quelque part effectivement 2014 a permis
aussi de consolider cet attachement à la
fois j'allais dire à l'état ukrainien
mais aussi aux territoires et en fait
pour les personnes de ces villes ces
villes sont ukrainiennes c'est comme ça
qu elles le vivent vladimir poutine on
le disait à sous-estimer la capacité de
mobilisation et de résistance
patriotique des ukrainiens
quasi logique un peu ce qu'il nie même
l'existence d'un peuple pouvoir d'une
identité ukrainienne or le peuple
ukrainien existe et vous l'appelez elle
l'avait rappelé récemment dans une
tribune depuis plus longtemps même que
son état il y aurait donc une mauvaise
analyse à y voir là une forme de sursaut
très récent
alors en fait je crois que la société
ukrainienne s'est développé de manière
totalement différente de la société
russe depuis depuis l'éclatement de
l'urss en ukraine on a eu des
révolutions politiques des alternances
politiques toute élection
en fait et
est liée à une incertitude on ne sait
pas qui va gagner l'élection toute forme
d'autoritarisme a été combattue par part
par la population donc en fait
effectivement on a progressivement un
imaginaire national ukrainien qui depuis
trente ans en fait c'est consolider et
aujourd'hui on a toute une génération
n'oublions pas que les trentenaires
aujourd'hui en ukraine n'ont pas vécu en
union soviétique et que quelque part ce
discours bien sûr qui précède la vision
parce qu'aujourd'hui je pense que l ce
discours n'est plus n'est plus
utilisable en ukraine 1 autour de
l'amitié entre les ans entre les peuples
par le nettement moins à 7 assez de
jeunes générations ou tout du moins
parle tant qu'il n'y a pas d' agression
aujourd'hui en fait il ya une dissonance
si je puis dire entre 7,7 ce discours là
et puis et puis cette invasion et puis
vous le rappelez bien sûr ce patriotisme
alimenter cet esprit de résistance par
le fait que la guerre et on n'a
peut-être pas assez parlé mea culpa la
guerre existe en ukraine depuis au moins
au moins huit ans de ce que vous savez
de ce qu'on vous témoigner notamment de
vos contacts à marioupol comment
comprenez vous
le le comment est ce que les ukrainiens
considère la ligne de crête sur laquelle
marche les européens qui seraient
soutenir l'ukraine sans entrer en guerre
directement est-ce que c'est accueilli
avec une forme de fatalisme avec une
forme de colère
je crois qu'il ya deux choses du point
de vue des dirigeants et on l'entend
dans la voix de volodymyr zelensky très
régulièrement qui intervient tous les
jours il ya à la fois des remerciements
fait notamment pour concernant l'aide
financière les livraisons d'armes et en
même temps une certaine rancoeur c'est à
dire aujourd'hui les ukrainiens qui se
battent sur le terrain les populations
qui sont sous les bombardements
notamment à marioupol mario paul qui est
encerclée dont je rappellerai que convoi
humanitaire est en attente un qui ne
peut être qu'il ne peut pas rentrer en
raison des bombardements bien sûr il ya
une très grande amertume les ukrainiens
ont le sentiment de se bat pour l'europe
c'est ce qu'ils disent et de ne pas être
suffisamment aidé le fameux slogan no
fly zone zone donc d'exclusion aérienne
eh bien là c'est bien évidemment un
appel qui revient sans cesse en ukraine
et pourquoi l'otan où les puissances
occidentales ne peuvent pas y répondre
parce que ça entraînerait un conflit on
va dire direct sur cette zone
d'exclusion aérienne fait en sorte que
des avions en fait de longs temps
devrait empêcher des avions on va dire
russe de
de survoler de survoler l'espace aérien
et craignent un essai entraînera une
confrontation directe vous confirmer
qu'un mario paul des contacts que vous
avez la situation humanitaire est
catastrophique
oui la situation et la situation
humanitaire est très très difficile et
il n'ya pas d'approvisionnement en
nourriture en eau
voilà et encore une fois le il ya des
bombardements des bombardements
incessants et juste pour un clin d'oeil
par rapport à l'actualité on voit que ce
matin on parle beaucoup de cette femme
sur les plateaux russe qui qui s'est
exprimé et bien en ukraine ont dit voilà
pendant ce temps là regardez ce qui se
passe nous sommes bombardés donc il ya
voilà une
une volonté en tous les cas de
cris d'appels et un appel à l'aide des
populations ukrainienne ce matin l'une
des forces de la de ce qu'on appelle
peut-être
avec une facilité intellectuelle la
résistance l'ukrainienne c'est ça c'est
sa communication
et son discours patriotique comment
au-delà du discours en réalité si j'ose
dire on voit comment les choses peuvent
évaluer le rapport de force est
clairement en défaveur des forces du
craignait n'est ce que derrière le
discours patriotique il ya parfois
quelque chose de l'ordre du réalisme
je crois qu'on saurait âgées bien sûr
tout à fait on cacher il ya déséquilibre
il ya une volonté de toute façon tout
est fait bien évidemment pour se donner
du courage se donner de la force
c'est ça en fait en ce moment cette
résilience c'est à dire cette volonté et
cette résistance elle est fondée
vraiment sur l'idée de mettre toutes les
forces de ceux de son côté pour là pour
gagner cette guerre en quelque sorte et
je crois que ce qui peut surprendre
aussi c'est dans cet élan patriotique
c'est comme quelque chose que dans on va
dire en europe on a un peu oublié cette
idée d'une nation qui est obligé de se
défendre par rapport à un envahisseurs
étrangers eh bien c'est ce que les
ukrainiens sont en train de vivre et je
crois que voilà ça c'est sans doute un
petit peu effacé dans un certain nombre
de nations on va dire européennes
installées dont l'indépendance n'est pas
menacé là on a véritablement à faire à
un peuple qui joue en quelque sorte
voilà la la la la survie de son état de
et 2 et 2 et de son peuple qui est qui
est donc menacée par par un parent
étranger dans le récit mais on comprend
pourquoi on parle évidemment peu ou pas
des ukrainiens qui sont contre la guerre
j'imagine qu'il y en a les ukrainiens
les hommes qui reste c'est parce qu'ils
le sont obligés ils doivent s'engager
entre 18 et 60 ans dans les forces us
craignait j'imagine qu'il y à des
ukrainiens qui ne veulent pas se battre
on ne les entend pas non c'est quelque
chose je pense qu'en fait aujourd'hui on
met vraiment l'accent sur voila c'est
cette force cette force patriotique
voilà existent ont certes utiles
je pense que dans tout enfin si vous
voulez dans cette société elle résiste
massivement et ça c'est c'est une chose
dans cette société ukrainienne elle est
hétérogène comme comme beaucoup d'autres
sociétés européennes donc une faune ni
idéalisé voilà le j'allais dire cette
société et son et son patriotisme qui
est existant on le voit mais bien
évidemment ici ou là on a des
témoignages d'hommes qui voilà qui ne
qui ne cherchent pas qu'ils ne cherchent
pas forcément à
combattre on a aussi des gens qui
reviennent sains notamment des
ukrainiens qui vivaient à l'étranger
depuis depuis un certain temps et qui
reviennent qui reviennent au pays pour
se battre donc je crois qu'on a vraiment
beaucoup de valable beaucoup d'opinions
et de façon de faire très très très très
différentes une petite question sur
l'avenir pour conclure
sombre ou en tout cas difficile de le
prédire la bien sûr mais sur vous disiez
tout à l'heure cette identité
ukrainienne peut-être comme partout dans
le monde d'ailleurs effet de complexité
comment il va imaginer
disons dans un scénario optimiste si la
guerre s'arrête et que les dégâts
restent ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
comment imaginer un vivre ensemble dans
ce pays fait de tant de diversité de
complexité de l'identité il n'y a pas
vraiment à mon sens il n'y a pas de
problème de vivre ensemble parce
qu'aujourd'hui en fait
la population qui vit en ukraine c'est
une population qui se sent
principalement on va dire ukrainienne
n'oublions pas on le rappeler en 2014 il
ya un conflit il ya un conflit à
l'extrême est du pays ce conflit a déjà
généré en fait un certain nombre de
migrations de population et une partie
de la population est par exemple allez
allez à l'époque en russie donc en
quelque sorte ce qui dope il que 2014
sont en ukraine ont décidé de rester en
ukraine et de soutenir cet état c'est
pour ça que le la perspective des huit
dernières années est extrêmement
importante finalement pour comprendre à
la fois cette résistance et ce vivre
ensemble ukrainien puisqu'on a déjà
éprouvé en quelque sorte et l'annexion
de la crimée et la guerre il y a huit
ans donc c'est déjà des questions ces
questions qui se sont posées sur ouche
je suis où je veux vivre quel état je
défende et n'oublions pas un volodymyr
zelensky hier à parler a commencé à
s'exprimer en dix ans les ukrainiens
libre c'est à dire que l'ukraine
aujourd'hui représente aussi cette
liberté cette liberté de vivre avec un
pluralisme politique et aujourd'hui la
russie ne représente pas on va dire un
modèle que les ukrainiens qui depuis
huit ans expérimentée souhaite on va
dire dans leur propre pays merci
beaucoup merci infiniment alexandra
goujon d'être revenue ce matin sur le
plateau de paris direct je rappelle le
titre de votre livre on le voit à
l'antenne l'ukraine de l'indépendance à
la guerre au cavalier bleu merci encore